in march more than a dozen european
countries suspended use of astrazeneca's
covet 19 vaccine because of concerns
over blood clotting
astrazeneca has said the clotting is not
related to the vaccine
and while the who and european medicines
agency are both conducting additional
reviews of the vaccine
they believe countries should not
suspend use of the vaccine
initially a lot of countries just stop
giving out the vaccine altogether
in the most recent days after the world
health organization came out and said
this isn't related some countries have
started giving the vaccine again
but they've placed some restrictions on
it so some countries like france have
said we'll give it but only to people
over the ages of 55
while other countries are still not
giving it out yet
experts are worried these steps could
erode people's willingness to get the
vaccine
largely due to an inadequate supply of
doses the european union has lagged
behind other countries in terms of their
vaccine rollout with
11.4 vaccinations for every 100 people
as of march
by comparison the u.s has 32.6
vaccinations per 100 people
and the uk leads the pack with 38.4 per
hundred
vaccine hesitancy which is another way
of saying
people who are afraid of getting
vaccines or who say they won't get
vaccines
is actually higher in western europe
than in the us
so it's already quite a problem there to
get some people to take the vaccines
and experts are worried that this issue
with astrozenica vaccines only
contributing to these worries
a lot of people have refused to take the
astrazeneca vaccine
and experts are concerned that this
could really harm the rollout
not only in europe but also in the u.s
since people in the us are reading all
these news reports
about issues in europe and it could make
people nervous
for if and when the vaccine does get
approved here in america
this kind of fear could have global
implications if enough people
choose not to get vaccinated we need
vaccines to end the pandemic
we need to reach what's called herd
immunity which is when a high percentage
of the population is vaccinated in order
to
end this pandemic and start resuming
life is normal
some experts say this is 60 of people
vaccinated some ex would say
70 and when people say that they're
afraid to take the vaccine or won't take
that vaccine
that means that this pandemic will just
last a lot longer and it means that
variants that could be more deadly and
more contagious have more time
to arise so we really want to get people
vaccinated as much as possible
and issues like holding vaccines like
what happened with astrozemica vaccine
can be really problematic because it can
just contribute to people being scared
of vaccines
of course we want to make sure the
vaccines are as safe as possible
but these vaccines have been really well
studied and the experts are saying that
there's no real risk here
earlier this week the national institute
of allergy and infectious diseases
expressed concern that astrazeneca quote
may have included outdated information
in its initial data of the us arm of its
covet 19 vaccine trials
on wednesday the company released
updated numbers from its u.s
phase 3 trials which show its vaccine is
effective against symptomatic disease
down from a previously claimed 79
efficacy
you